let's kick this conversation up to the
next level oh my god here we go
trump fires defense secretary in
post-election reckoning after policy
splits
he didn't just get rid of defense
secretary mark esper he got rid of like
the top brass the pentagon
yeah and you know what the you know
these leftists are saying journalists
are saying
this is him stacking the the deck with
loyalists as he plans a coup
and i gotta say i don't know why trump
would fire these people a few months
before he's supposed to vacate assuming
he loses
maybe he's just operating assuming he's
going to win but the rumor was he was
going to fire them after he got
reelected
he's doing it during what what made it
being a lame duck session
which makes me wonder about what might
happen and why he needs to get rid of
people who may be
you know he may have issues with i don't
know
i'm not ready to go there but i will
admit
that in reading uh about the
terminations and about some of the
personnel placement that's been put over
at the pentagon in
varying positions of power chief of
staff some others
knowing that there's some real hardcore
trump loyalists being placed over at
defense department
it did make me wonder just why now one
of the first questions i come to mind
is like is there any precedent has an
outgoing
uh president had a change of you know
house and leadership at the end of the
term maybe there's some reason for it i
don't know i bet there's a reason
but just thinking about some of the
people who were placed over there
and uh and just it just makes you wonder
who did he play
he plays cash patel who's that uh cash
patel uh
worked with devin nunes during the
russia gate
uh phenomenon you know scandal and he
was present uh in the
in the house hearings i believe and and
was there
and witnessed the evidence and the
testimony that was presented and all the
guys coming in and they all said to them
you know to the hearing that
there's no evidence of any collusion or
whatever and then he
you know was part of sort of the
whistleblowing process and the nunes
memo that came out
and all of that and so uh he he
definitely been putting in a lot of hard
work on behalf of the republic
let's not forget this is not he's not
like a trump loyalist that went and did
something that was wrong no he's
unearthing information about
wrongdoing done by the democratic party
so he's working on behalf
of the citizens of the united states
people that voted donald trump in office
and anyone who respects
the rural law in america that said he's
a proven
you know trump loyalist and he's been
placed over a chief of staff of some
high up office
department now i have no idea why and i
know there's people in my network that
are probably mad that i'm talking about
this i don't know i have questions it's
public information available information
it's not like uh i'm revealing anything
but
you do have to wonder why i'm going to
go with that there's a real
normal perspective i got some questions
the pentagon so um are they in control
of the fbi and the cia
that's department of justice um
i think that he's was upset with the way
that the pentagon handled this
voting thing and believes that there's
all sorts of is it important
and fraud this is the department of
defense is like afghanistan iraq iran
yeah yeah okay so maybe i'm wrong so the
doj is handling the vote fraud stuff
and the top uh doj guy resigned when
bill barr issued a memo on investigating
vote fraud claims
so the pentagon is defense so now
they're saying like trump is going to
make a move in iran or something like
that
i don't know what he's doing but uh
there's no way does it sound like does
it sound like counting heads
counting heads for what like who's with
me who's not that's yeah so in a civil
way
in a civil war or a coup oh jesus before
he wants the department of defense on
his side
before the civil war breaks out the top
leaders of each faction start counting
heads
who which departments do i have matt
taibbi wrote about this in october
the counting heads phase is when you've
got
the the commander general or whatever
who's like i'm gonna take over and you
got the president
and they start calculating what do i
have i have the department of defense
i have the chief of police i don't have
the fbi to figure out where their
loyalists are and what assets they have
in the event of a coup
civil war whatever but also you said he
was going to fire these people anyway
and now rumor the rumor was once he got
reelected he was gonna fire um
with gina haspel uh chris chris ray of
the fbi so she's uh
she she was um what was hospital she was
a nsa i don't recall i know that
christopher wray has to go though yeah
he was the fbi and then esper is the
he was the defense secretary was he yeah
christopher way is the one who's got his
head up
his own butt about white supremacy being
the most dangerous domestic
threat that we face like get out of town
buddy yeah right it's climate change
isn't it
i'm just i'm just kidding this isn't a
giant asteroid pajama man
cia she was the head of the scene so
he's just got rid of these people anyway
before
it becomes official if it does that
biden is president-elect he doesn't want
to do it after that because it's going
to look
really shady um so i think he's just
getting out of the way what do you mean
if
if donald trump lost then his only
opportunity is to do it right now
i'm sorry if donald trump loses the
election he
the results are in for biden if donald
trump doesn't get certified the winner
his only opportunity to remove haspel
esper and rey is right now before
january 4th
well i i guess okay he could wait till
january and he would look like a
criminal if he was doing it after that
vote
tally was already in biden's favor
because oh i see you mean after january
14th i mean i'm sorry december december
14th after the certification process
just getting out of the way so it seems
maybe but then what they could rehire
them if they want i know
that's why i would but but trump
replaced them with loyalists
so that's
no what trump's problem is the biggest
number one problem aside from whatever
his personality issues may be
is his personnel and hiring decisions oh
god i know number one
number one john bolton what was he
thinking no i'm not even talking about
that i'm talking about the thousands of
political appointees
the deep the staffers here and there and
there and just the people who are in the
white house or in westwood who are like
maga for real like who are down with the
cause and volunteered on the campaign
and part of the network that launched
trump into power they are you can like
count them on a
short list and they are isolated and
they've been fighting
and battling the bureaucracy and they
call it the deep state same thing
people that didn't want to see their
agenda get pushed through whether
they're leftover democrats or gop
establishment people or just milctose
conservatives that weren't ready for a
right you know right side revolution
that trump represented
and he's been fighting that all along
number one criticism everybody's made it
of him is personnel there's no question
about it
and uh you know if only he would have
just fired people that he didn't think
were doing what he wanted a long time
ago
and just put the right people in place
from the jump and stood up for
flynn and all uh he was he was jammed up
in the beginning though yeah
with russiagate he couldn't he couldn't
he couldn't fire half these people
and i wonder you know uh
what he who we would have hired who he
would have fired i i certainly think he
would have fired comey and a bunch of
people immediately
but they they argued that would have
been obstruction of justice and then
when he did they launched the
investigation against him to stop him
from doing this
the russiagate stuff was looming before
we had a special prosecutor right indeed
then they retaliated because it was he
fired comey and that sparked
the start of it right yeah it sure did
then comey was like i remember trump
said this and i wrote it down and it's
like that's not proof he said it like
that's crazy
right i just wrote it down but you know
i hate to say it but you kind of have to
hand it to the democrats man they have
run
i mean a really hard campaign they lost
the election they weren't going to stand
for it they were going to prevent trump
from doing whatever you know trump
wanted they've been fighting and
fighting and fighting dirty and fighting
consistently and they have not given up
and they're still not giving up and
they're still pushing on i mean they
have some stamina there's no question
well it's the media they have the media
on their side
yeah they have establishment media
saying everything i mean uh
even daily mail they wrote an article
about the 234 pages pages of
testimony statements from these uh
witnesses
and the way the daily mail framed it was
was remarkable it was like they took the
worst of the accusations and made a joke
out of it
ignoring uh they took the silliest
ignoring the worst so i'm seeing a bunch
of leftists on twitter do this
and it's probably because they're dumb
and they want to rile up their base but
they're saying things like
this guy is arguing that the military
shouldn't vote for biden
in in one statement the guy says i saw a
military ballot that was for biden that
struck me as odd
and they're laughing at him like what an
idiot then you have one where a woman
says my son's been dead for eight years
but somehow he's listed as voting the
election twice
they ignore that one wow and that's in
what the rnc has released or what trump
can't pay or whoever has released in 234
pages
the rnc says they have 11 000 people who
have come forward with claims of fraud
yeah do we just say we ignore eleven
thousand pay attention
or is the rnc lying what do you do when
the second biggest political party in
this country says we have 11 000 people
coming forward
this is not some random tinfoil hat guy
yelling there was fraud in the election
this is literally the second biggest
political party in the country saying we
have evidence we have witnesses
you have to honor it for sure for sure
but i mean
beyond that it says something truly
terrifying about the direction we're
headed
like as as if if the republicans win
this and it turns out there was front of
the democrats cheated the democrats are
going to be like oh you got us
good game everybody will play again next
time no what are they going to do if
they get caught they actually did
something
yeah what are the republicans going to
do if it turns out they were lying the
whole time
and there was no evidence and they're
just trying to scam the election either
outcome is terrifying yeah i mean look
i do remember seeing a collection of
clips from fox news i think they were
talking about the stacey abrams thing a
couple years ago
fox news all saying all the same things
today
about challenging this and challenging
that or no it was like why are you
challenging just accept it again
everybody will say whatever they need to
say to get their guy in the power
there's no question about it but if we
can go
the hard data analytic route
with hard evidence narrow down the mass
pool of votes narrow it down to people
that
that have circumstances that are
questionable
narrow that down narrow it down narrow
it down and then you're gonna find
you will find instances of fraud and
malfeasance there's no question about it
but we it's like we live in a country
that's so big now
that little instances of violence here
and there when they get put up on social
media it makes it look like there's
violence everywhere makes it look like
all the cities in every country in every
state are all burning down to the ground
makes it look like all the whole city of
minneapolis is burned to the ground but
it's not or in dc that they're rioting
all over the whole city but they're not
it's
a lot it's frequent it's damaging it's
bad but it's not everywhere
so i imagine what this is the same thing
while large numbers here where like hey
there's so many people voting were we up
to 140 million or something
almost 150 almost 150 million people
what if like 0.001
of them are screwy that's still a ton
yup
still a million people it's still a ton
right
it's fewer than that you can find
thousands and thousands of instances
even i think probably in any
circumstance it doesn't mean it was okay
back then
yeah and it's definitely not okay now
and this is a good chance as any
you know if the democrats had any real
gumption or if they were actually
dedicated to the united states of
america
they would say well you know one good
thing is going to come out of donald
trump
we are going to really once and for all
get to the bottom of potential election
fraud put
election month feasings we're going to
get this system tightened up and we're
not going to let this crap happen again
in the future
but they're not saying that no they're
saying stop yeah don't look don't
look that's the worst sign that is the
worst sign
that they have absolutely no no no basis
in value
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time